measure the angle in degrees
so here we have this blue angle that we
want to measure in degrees
and it's sitting on top of this circle
that circle is actually a protractor
sometimes we see and maybe what you're
used to seeing is protractors that are
more semi-circle shaped something like
this
and those semi-circle protractors
measure from 0 to 180 degrees
which is good but a circle is even
better a full circle is better because
an angle can measure up to 360 degrees
so a full circle allows us to measure an
angle of any size instead of only an
angle up to 180 degrees
now the way we're going to measure this
angle
is the same way we would on a
semi-circle protractor the first thing
we want to do is make sure one of our
rays lines up to zero
so here's one of our rays and it's
lining up to zero on the protractor so
that's nice it's already lined up for us
and then we're going to measure the
opening all the way to the other ray to
right here
and so if our angle only measured opened
up this far it would be a 10 degree
angle if let's say it opened to here it
would be a 50 degree angle
but our angle measures all the way to
here to the 160 degrees
so
160 degrees
is the measure
of our angle
and again
when you measure on a circle protractor
or any protractor for that matter
you're going to line one ray up to the
zero
and then measure the opening
till you get to the other ray which in
this case opened up to
160 degrees